how shocked were you to see that night  sacrifice no it's not shark like it's  one of the moves I was considering but  yeah just it's just bad yeah like I can  defend uh very very different accurately  it's uh just meaningful way like  was it more of a surprise for you that  he went for it because it looked like he  had a pleasant position uh no it was  I wouldn't say it's a surprise but  it was one of the most I was considering  but I was expecting uh  [Music]  you mentioned you're gonna take the good  positives from yesterday you've taken  the lead in this match how are you  feeling going into game two no there is  still three more games and a lot of  things happen in three games uh still  have to concentrate it all the best